- He's coding.
Nurse, get five cc's of parallelograms
and one Sega Genesis.
(laughter)
- Tik, tok, tik, tok, doopity doo.
I've got some medical
laughs analysis for you.
Peewoop.
- [Female Speaker] You
don't have a double chin.
What you do have is bad posture.
So all you need to do is two steps,
bring your shoulders up, back and down,
bring your chin slightly
forward and then slightly down,
and look at the difference that makes.
(laughter)
- It's backwards.
No, you want to keep your shoulders open,
chest open, facing the world,
ready to take on challenges.
I don't know if you noticed,
I've started working out again,
I'm really sore and this really hurts.
- [Male Speaker] Things
Tik Tok made me buy.
- Oh.
- [Male Speaker] This is a phone charger
that supposedly leads you
to the strongest power
source in the entire house.
Oh no.
(laughter)
- Oh, it went to a mitochondria.
Powerhouse of the cell.
Touche.
(clapping)
Golf clap for that.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
This gives new meaning
to walking your dog.
Honestly, if my dog walked like that,
I wouldn't put it on a leash.
I would just say like look,
my dog walks next to me.
I would hold its paw.
When you finally get that long white coat
and your boys invite you
over to watch the game.
Students wear short
lab coats, white coats,
and doctors wear long ones.
So if you ever see people
in short white coats
walking around they could be students.
- I can't take it off. I
can't take it off, like.
- Take it off.
- I can't.
- I can't take it off. Like.
- Take it off.
- I can't.
- You don't want to take it off.
I remember when I was a student
and I went through my white coat ceremony
and I had my white coat
for the first time,
I remember pulling up to
Coney Island Hospital,
parking my car two blocks away,
and proudly wearing the white coat
as I walked the two blocks from my car.
When really I still had like
seven years of education left.
Mm. This is going to be stressful.
- Do you remember that patient
you saw yesterday for chest pain?
(somber piano music)
- Malpractice lawyers near me.
Fired doctor. Anything helps.
- Yes. How come?
- I ran into her today.
She's doing so much better.
Thanks for your care.
- It's so true.
I will literally have someone
from my office staff say,
"Oh, you know that patient
you saw for something?"
And the anxiety levels start creeping up,
like, did something bad happen?
Did they file a complaint?
And it's not because that happens often.
In fact, that's really
rare for it to happen,
but it, like, there's this fear
that you did something wrong
because you want to do right by everybody.
It is scary.
You want the best for your patients.
And as a doctor you're
going to miss stuff,
you're going to misdiagnose things,
because patients' conditions don't always
present so clearly.
They take time to develop.
Part of the art of medicine.
- Oh. I have such a bad headache.
- I have essential oils.
- Wait, is this safe?
- Of course, doctors use it all the time.
- Essential oil.
- It literally cures anything.
Here. Breathe this for 30 seconds.
Keep breathing it in.
- It's burning my eyes.
- That means it's working. Closer.
You have to believe in it or it won't --
- He's just like chloroforming
her with the essential oil.
- -- or it won't work.
- My eyes are literally burning.
- You're almost through the crystal.
Just keep breathing.
- I don't want to do this any more.
- He threw in a Reiki crystal.
- Just one more. Feel better?
- My headache's gone.
- I told you.
- Wait. Is that grapefruit.
- Yeah. Why?
- I'm allergic.
- So I don't have an
essential oil for that.
- He's going to need an EpiPen,
and luckily he's not
over the Atlantic Ocean.
If you haven't seen that story of mine,
Watch me as I try to break it.
(laughter)
- Oh, what?
Okay.
I don't know if this person
is a legitimate doctor.
I don't know what the purpose
of fighting that saline implant was.
I don't know the durability
of saline implants,
but I'd like to think
they're quite durable.
I don't know if they're made
to be twisted and turned like that,
and I've actually had patients come in
who had an implant that
ruptured, saline implant.
The one experience I've had was
a patient came in and
she walked into this,
like the edge of her car door,
and she like, kind of turned in
and didn't expect the door to be there
and it punctured the implant.
Oh, that hurt.
But we right away got her an
urgent plastic surgery eval
and it got figured out.
- Sweetheart, there's no need to worry.
You won't feel a thing.
- Why when anyone on Tik Tok
tries to play a female character,
they put a disgusting
white towel on their head,
and they're like, oh that's
somehow represents female hair.
- Okay?
(screaming)
- If you ever enter a
pediatrician's office,
or a family medicine doctor's office,
there are screams galore.
That is part of the process,
because children are naturally nervous.
They get scared, there
is stranger anxiety.
This is part of normal development.
When we give vaccines, even
if it doesn't hurt that much,
it's scary.
Imagine a stranger
bringing a needle to you.
So yes, there are screams all the time.
My strategy, is to give
the child a distraction,
and sometimes a present
before I do anything.
Not, I'll give you a
lollipop if you listen,
but here's a lollipop so you'll listen.
- I just want you to know that
I miss you and I love you.
Can't wait for this show to be over --
- Oh.
- -- so that I can touch people.
- Touch people. Mm.
No, honestly, like I want to go back,
this sounds weird, but to touching people.
I want to go back to shaking hands.
Insider, I don't know if you follow that,
it's an Instagram account,
they recently posted that,
like handshakes are about to
become a thing of the past.
No, it's not, Insider.
Handshakes are an important part
of non-verbal communication for humans.
It's how we trust others.
It's how we show we have no weapons,
from back in the day.
But it's like a way to
communicate with someone.
A handshake tells a lot about that person,
about your relationship,
about how you're going to communicate.
And the fact that there's
a pandemic going on,
sure, we can suspend it now,
but it doesn't mean we need
to be afraid of all germs
and become germophobic.
Pandemic, no handshakes,
no pandemic, handshakes.
See how that works?
We don't have to swing the
pendulum the complete other way
every time something happens.
(upbeat music)
(laughter)
That's funny.
Oh my God.
So yeah, there is Hodgkin's
and non-Hodgkin's lymphoma,
and again, they're using the little towel
and the pillowcases for the hair.
I don't get it.
♪ Come with me and you'll be ♪
♪ In a world of hippaviolations. ♪
(laughter)
♪ Hippaviolations. ♪
- For those of you who don't know,
Hippa is Health Information
Patient Protection Act,
(buzzer)
Health Information Patient
Protection Accountability Act,
(buzzer)
Health Information Protection
Accountability Act,
(buzzer)
oh no.
It's down below.
(orchestral music)
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
When I was in the hospital
and I worked a 36-hour shift,
I wasn't like,
(bell pings)
in fact, when you're leaving the hospital
after a 24-hour, 36-hour shift,
you're literally walking
with your eyes half closed,
body fluids all over your
scrubs, placenta on your shoe
if you're working in the OB department.
Residency is a hard time.
There would be a period
where I wouldn't see
my friends for a month.
And they were like, where were you?
I'm like, ICU life, six
days a week, 18-hour days.
Tough.
- Good morning, sexy doctors,
and welcome to "Hospital".
Six of you will die this season,
and I don't want to catch any of you
having sex in the on call room,
unless it's with me.
He's coding.
Nurse, get five cc's of parallelograms
and one Sega Genesis.
(laughter)
The chest compressions are like this,
and she's getting
parallelograms and Sega Genesis,
which is the first ever video
game console I've owned.
God, that's brilliant.
Medical dramas are so inaccurate.
Uh-oh.
Are they cutting into it
with a Cuisinart knife?
That is not an approved
medical piece of technology.
That's made for chicken and steaks.
That was a good flap.
I'm not going to lie, solid flap.
(laughter)
Was that supposed to be
a delivery of macaroni's.
Those are little macaroni's.
How did they get the
macaroni's inside the banana?
You guys are going to
probably laugh at me.
Those aren't macaroni's.
Those are like fettucini's or,
God, what's like the long pasta called?
(frustrated grunt)
It starts with a Z, no it doesn't.
Let's give another huge
thank you to ExpressVPN
for sponsoring this video.
The link is down below.
Click it to get up to three months free
and if you want to know
how I got into med school,
click here for this video.
And if you want to see
how I stay productive,
with some easy tips for you, click here
for a productivity 101 video.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
Which one are clicking on?
(instrumental music)